what are you doing
how do you see me say ah
[Music]
hey you want me some hot dogs hot dogs
yeah
yeah you do
fine
thank god you didn't die just then hot
diggity dog we are right now on our way
to eat three of the best hot dogs at
three drastically different price points
to find out which one is the most worth
it at its price what makes a good hot
dog it's really about the the whole
package you need a good bun are you a
bun guy i mean i'm not just eating hot
dogs without buns that's disgusting look
at that that's a falcon
on the fence right there
wait don't take the whole thing off
don't scare it
no
wow
[Music]
my name is william fidel you're at
vicious dogs restaurant in north
hollywood we serve hot dogs galore and
where does the name come from years and
years ago when we used to eat hot dogs
over actually at pinks we used to always
say boy these dogs are vicious because
you know we just enjoyed eating hot dogs
so vicious dogs is from an la hot dog
upbringing absolutely today i'm going to
be serving you my basic hot dog it's a
dollar ninety-nine and we're gonna top
it with ketchup mustard relish onions it
is the most traditional hot dog in los
angeles actually across america the
secret is making sure that you find the
best quality hot dog start there and you
finish there he recommended that we get
the hot dog with a fries and a coke
that's it what about these hot peppers
for our hot dogs what are they for we're
burning your butt hot dog high five
let's go
[Music]
wow
for a hot bottle i like to have that
snap back when i bite into a hot dog
yeah and you get that's important bun is
soft but not mushy it doesn't like
crumble or get too damp in your fingers
which is nice wholesome satisfying
perfect i wanted to more fried you on it
sucks to start good and then after that
i'm going to make you my favorite hot
dog which is my signature sweet and
spicy kielbasa it's a actual one-third
pound kielbasa we char-boil it to
perfection we put sweet chili glaze on
there grilled onions grilled peppers we
put it snuggly in a little poppy seed
but it is that good and then my
signature dog is six dollars out of the
100 plus hot dogs that we've created
here every single one of them has its
own distinct flavor this is a much more
formidable hot dog some of them built
and now we eat it
you know that
it's a house that's pretty good that's
pretty great the sweetness really plays
with the smokiness i just love how when
you bite into it it's like you're just
getting a big hunk of meat i don't want
to finish it because i wanted to be
savoring it i want to finish it oh
the hot dog was a hot dog and that's
what i liked about it it wasn't
mind-blowing but it was satisfying where
else can you get an item of food that
will fill you up for two dollars you
know what i'm ready for hot dog facts
give me your hot dogs bag hot dogs
are not dogs hot dog fact h o t hot dots
mickey mouse's first words
were hot dogs really
yeah hot dog did he say it like that
oh no i got a hot dog please the next
place i don't know how to pronounce it
though because it's a german name i
think it's pronounced
hopefully they can teach how to say the
name of the restaurant yeah hopefully
they know the place that they work
[Music]
so steve and andrew well welcome to
voice cooka today we're going to oh
that's how you pronounce it
my cousin and i opened this store in
2008 here in the arts district since
then we've been serving nothing other
than beer sausage and belgian style
fries perfect perfect combination so the
name and the overall format is
reminiscent of like a german beer hall
your first time to the restaurant you're
going to walk into a dining room that is
just warm fun and inviting once you sit
down you've already paid for your food
you want another beer you go get one if
you just want to hang out and draw on
the tables and talk you go for it we're
going to get started with the lamb
sausage completely pork free for anybody
who chooses not to eat pork our sausages
have a choice of pour toppings
caramelized onions sweet peppers spicy
peppers and sauerkraut i do have a
question i am actually not a beer guy do
you have a beer recommendation though of
somebody like me the first one i'm going
to recommend would be duchess to begonia
you're either going to love it or you're
going to be like uh really so we're
starting off with the beer that he
recommended the duchess to berganyo
[Music]
really it's goddamn fruit punch it's my
kind of beer no it's delicious but it's
like adam tell me what this tastes like
this is starburst so first up is lamb
with mediterranean spices they want to
make sure all of the sausages are four
ounces the lamb actually two ounces per
sausage they double up and they put two
in one bun it's like us two is adam the
bottom you're the bun that holds us
together adam all right i'm gonna get
the mustard do not eat anything when i'm
gone i'll be right back
hey
so he recommended the spicy brown as his
favorite high five up high yeah
down low
in the middle
huh in your face
you like the chase to blame oh yeah
everybody is so satisfied because you
get that snap every single time here you
get two snaps double barrel sausage very
lamy true to its name and it is a bit of
a muskier flavor this is going to be the
best lame sausage you ever ate oh boy
i'm in love and then we have a fun one
rattlesnake and rabbit which is one of
our top sellers so when we order the
rattlesnake what happens in the kitchen
the world of sausage hasn't changed ever
sausages are made ahead of time and when
you order it we throw it on the grill
the first sausage we've had that's
shaped like the animal it comes from ooh
smells nice and spicy
very interesting the more i eat the more
i'm into it it's a lot gamier taste but
it is really good i have had like
crocodile meat and it was as close to
that as any other meat i've ever had i
think this is the most you've ever eaten
on an episode because i love hot dogs
i'm a hot dog honcho kablamo
and now with our final hot dog bag hot
dog fan
the most expensive hot dog is 169
and it exists in seattle washington
foreshadowing
what we're going to seattle washington
baby for this video yes we're meeting
tomorrow at the airport at 4 30 a.m and
we're going to see 4 30 a.m hot dog fact
i'm not doing that yeah you are bad
boom
sausage dance
one two three four
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we have flown many many miles to come to
the most expensive hot dog in the world
which i had to order by the way two
weeks ago all the trees are changing
color it's beautiful
what could make these hot dogs better
than the sausages we had at versus
i just can't think straight i ate hot
dogs all of yesterday you're living the
dream the dream i'm telling you
we're here today at cookie dog food
truck i'm eugene this is samson we are
co-creators of the most expensive hot
dog in the world it's 169 here is the
guinness world record plaque oh so it's
official tell us a little more about
tokyo dog we were both in the tech
industry about five years ago i was like
well what would be fun is to open a food
truck how did you come up with this
crazy hot dog we wanted to do something
really fun and bring the record home and
it's a fundraising hot dog we donated
all the proceeds to the red cross we
spent about three months creating this
hot dog and we came up with women's
brioche month smoked cheese bratwurst
fogwa
wagu beef maitake mushrooms butter
teriyaki onions japanese mayo black
truffles caviar and it is phenomenal
we flew all the way from la to try this
hot dog can you not devour this one so
fast yeah i have a problem eating things
a little bit too quickly not savoring
them but i think this one is going to
require some special attention we've
reached the final place after it's 690
miles of traveling the 169 dollar
junibon dog we usually drink wine at the
last spot but well this is the wine of
japan
i don't think that's true
cheers
oh this is so good everything on this
we've had in some shape or form except
for the caviar this is a lot more
food than a lot of the other dogs the
titanic of hot dogs yeah and i am the
iceberg about to take this bad boy down
feel like it's time to eat high five
[Music]
holy shmoley
that's wow hands down the best hot dog
experience i've ever had it's massive
got truffle coming to the left caviar
uppercut from the bottom
you got the dog cheese squirting out at
you it's a flavor explosion oreo mmm the
craziest part to me is you've got all
these incredible ingredients on top and
the dog itself still shines through with
flavor everything else is like a
glamorous costume for it it took them 10
tries they said to get to this dog
balancing which ingredient to use this
moment right now i never wanted to end
you know what
it never will end because look how much
dog we got left i think you actually ate
more than me this time i'm gonna eat
this whole thing are you for real
i can't believe we just ate a 169 hot
dog and it was worth it
mission complete
what a day what a dog technically this
dog cost like over a thousand dollars
why because i bought you guys plenty
tickets to seattle
which dog slash sausage was the most
worth it at its price the tokyo dog was
a little bit crazy but at least you're
giving to charities but for me the
winners burst crew because they have
those unique dogs at a reasonable price
dog i want to save vicious dogs because
i love a good deal my vote actually and
probably very stupidly goes to tokyo
down this whole experience flying to
seattle with you guys and experiencing
that monstrosity was like one of the
most fun times of my life oh my god are
you about to propose i think it's safe
to say that if a hot dog is in your hand
and you're eating it that's a good dog
fact
if you stick a hot dog on each of your
fingers and go like this
you'll have a hot dog
oh yes